on a vu les travaux de cette commission
déclenchée par ce chiffre qui avait été
donnée à l'hiver dernier le président du
conseil scientifique qui paraît de 20%
de lui fermer faute de soignants c'est
ce qui avait déclenché la commission
d'enquêté a donc rendu son rapport ce
matin et vous n'avez pas pu vérifier ou
voilà dire que ce chiffre était vrai ou
pas parce qu'en fait il n'y a pas
d'indicateur et vous le regrettez n'est
ce pas oui aussi incroyable que ça
puisse paraître l'état n'est pas en
mesure de fournir une évaluation précise
du nombre de lits hospitaliers qui ont
été fermées par par défaut si vous
voulez du nombre de lits qui sont
ouverts actuellement et par spécialité
mais ce qu'on a constaté c'est que de
toute façon il ya effectivement eu délit
qui ne sont pas ouverts et par manque de
personnel et que de fait
l'hôpital fonctionne en flux tendu
exactement et fonctionne depuis
longtemps en flux tendu et que ce c'est
une des sources du problème et de la
crise que vit l'hôpital louis-h dans le
rapport qu'il vous rendez publie
aujourd'hui on comprend que la clé de
voûte c'est bien la souffrance des
personnels que vous avez notamment
auditionné au sénat vous appelez à des
revalorisations salariales au delà de ce
qui a été fait pour le ségur de la santé
et al embauche mais si aussi
d'infirmières et d'aides-soignantes
c'est ça la clé de voûte de votre
rapport wisair que l'essentiel c'est la
crise de sens les personnels ne
comprennent plus ce qu'on leur demande
et donc il faut redonner du sens à la
mission de l'hôpital il faut redonner du
sens à des personnels qui nous l'ont
tous deux dits ont le sentiment d'être
mal traitant de ne pas bien prendre en
charge les patients kruyt donc ça prend
ça passe par des mesures très concrètes
ça passe par une proposition que nous
faisons qui est très forte qui est
d'améliorer les ratios de soignants par
patient oui se sont dégradées ces
dernières années et vous savez quand une
infirmière qui devait prendre en charge
du patient en prend en charge 14 et ben
n'a plus le temps de faire correctement
son travail donc nous appelons à ce que
ses ratios soit améliorée ce qu'est ce
qui est un système d' alerte quand ils
sont trop bas et puis des mesures de
revalorisation mais des mesures aussi de
participation à la gouvernance de
l'hôpital louis-h pour que la logique
soignante soit vraiment la logistique
lapins des rentes que des personnels
administratifs qui contrôle les hôpitaux
mais que les soignants soit égal intégré
dans la prise des décisions de ce qui se
passe dans l'hôpital c'est ça ce qu'on
constate c'est que les personnels
administratifs et les personnels de
direction sont engagés comme les
personnels soignants dans l'hôpital il
faut que les uns et les autres
travaillent plus de façon coordonnée et
ensemble et pour cela il faut tourner la
page d'un hôpital qui fait trop peu de
place à la logique soignante dans la
prise des décisions parmi les autres
idées et qu'il y ait dans votre rapport
il ya et bien toutes ces propositions
pour rendre attractif à nouveau le
métier de soignant également le fait de
simplifier les démarches administratives
ou encore de soulager les services
d'urgence avec les infirmières dans les
ehpad par exemple pour le pack il est
comme cela des urgences qui soit sûre
sollicité pour vous retenez tout cette
série de mesures sont applicables très
rapidement vous dit pas besoin de passer
par une loi non il n'y a pas besoin de
passer par une loi et ça c'est une
question de volonté politique
c'est qu'est ce qu'on demande à notre
hôpital de remplir comme mission et
quels moyens on lui donne pour remplir
cette mission vous prenez l'exemple des
ehpad la nuit ce n'est pas un sujet
qu'il ya intra hospitalier mais le fait
qu'il n'y ait pas d'infirmières dans les
ehpad la nuit qui est trop peu de
personnel fait qu' on en voit des
personnes âgées à l'hôpital alors qu on
pourrait l'éviter donc on voit aussi à
travers cette cet exemple là qu'une
partie une partie des projets des
solutions à la crise actuelle de
l'hôpital se trouve aussi en dehors de
l'hôpital dans le rapport de l'hôpital
avec les autres acteurs du système de
soins avec le médico-social et avec le
système de soins ambulatoires par
exemple sur la question des urgences
autre volet de ce rapport rendu public
aujourd'hui bernard jomier c'est tout le
volet sur le financement hôpital ce
financement un qui fait l'objet de
négociations autour de l'ondam vous
dites qu'il faut revoir la finance
aujourd'hui l'hôpital public oui parce
que quand on regarde l'histoire de
l'ondam s'est dit choqué donc
l'indicateur c'est le sait c'est
l'objectif des dépenses qu'ils aient
voté chaque année par le parlement la
sécurité qui est une construction qui
est trop financière est ce que nous
disons c'est que on doit reconnecter
c'est notre proposition l'ondam aux
besoins de santé de l'hôpital et donc on
doit changer la façon dont on construit
le budget de l'hôpital et puis on doit
est réduit ir la part de tarification à
l'activité parce que en gros on paye
l'hôpital à l'activité pour certaines
activités cette instance aura mais on le
paye pas suffisamment et pour d'autres
des patients complexe des patients
chroniques des patients âgés eh bien on
le paye trop mal et donc il faut changer
ça et il faut introduire dans le
financement c'est notre proposition une
part qu'on appelle populationnelle c'est
justement pour prendre en compte ce type
de patients bernard jeu mais nous reste
30 secondes à quoi peut servir votre
rapport désormais il est comme ça dans
les dents le débat public mais est-ce
que vous allez l'envoyer à olivier vers
enfin que quelle est la suite maintenant
pour ce rapport et rapports du publi du
sénat sont tous publics et j'espère que
les prochains gouvernements quels qu'ils
soient s'appuieront sur nos
recommandations
[Musique]